قد تبدو هذه الاجواء هادئه لكنها اشبه
باجواء ما قبل العاصفه عاصفه رياحها
الرئيس الامريكي السابق دونالد ترامب بعد
ان سيطر على شاشات التلفزه بدعوه انصاره
لتنظيم احتجاجات حاشده
الاحتجاجات المرتقبه اقلقت السلطات
الامريكيه من تكرار سيناريو اقتحام
الكابيتول الامريكي على يد مناصري ترامب
وامكانيه خروجها عن نطاق السيطره وتحولها
الى عمليات عنف وتخريب وفيما يشبه الهجوم
المضاد ندد رئيس مجلس النواب الامريكي
كيفن ماكارتي بتحقيق المدعي العام بحق
ترامب واصفا الامر بالمسيس رئيس مجلس
النواب الامريكي كيفن ماكارتي
لا يهم اي جانب من المشكله انت الان لا
يهم ما اذا كان هذا هو الرئيس ترامب او
اذا كان ديمقراطيه يجب ان تكون هذه عداله
متساويه في امريكا وان تتوقف عن ملاحقه
الناس لان لديهم خلافات سياسيه
دعوه ترامب للتصعيد في الشارع رافقها
تاييد من كبار المسؤولين ابرزهم
السيناتورلينز جراهم الذي حث ترامب على
المقاومه واخذ القضيه الى المحكمه العليا
تصعيد الجمهوريين قابله اخر ديمقراطي
بدعوى انما يجري محاولات جديده لخدمه
مصالح ترامب
السيناتور الديمقراطيه اليزابيث وورن
مص
الح لنكن واضحين بشان ما يحدث هنا لا احد
فوق القانون ولا حتى الرئيس السابق
للولايات المتحده
التصعيد الحاصل بين جمهوري وديمقراطي يبقي
الشارع الاميركي ومعه العالم مترقبا لما
سينتهي اليه الامر امر قد ياخذ امريكا الى
ابعد من هذا المشهد